I'm gonna move this yearning add to the
centerfold centerfold always the best
part am I right Justin damn and broke up
six weeks ago yeah Jerry I need to see
your softball pictures here you go teeth
Wow
good job isn't that that creepy guy
Morgan the pedophile yeah it is oh he
seemed okay oh we had dinner together
guys I don't know if I made it clear but
I don't want any sex offenders in our
parks catalog yeah I will Photoshop his
face can you photoshop your life with
better decisions Jerry okay April enough
here's what I think we should do
everyone should go around and say one
thing that they love about Tom
I'll start I really wish I could have
your body what Oh like tied up naked in
your basement no no I mean you're in
good shape and you can eat whatever you
want well that was weird
Jerry people behead that usage report
that I asked for
[Music]
anything for you Jerry thank you oh come
on why okay here's a memo with some
facts about little Sebastian you'll find
yours particularly interesting it's just
a list of facts mm-hmm okay
mine says you have a cute butt hmm it's
weird must be a typo
yeah Jerry is probably a typo because it
probably should have said you have a
cube but your butt's shaped like a cute
yeah the question is why he's my
amendment different than everyone else's
cube butt cube butt cube so as we know
spring hunting season is a promise
anyway here's the info about the new
licensing system Jerry I don't I don't
think your computer's blended I'm sorry
guys just got a powerup first thing we
should have is my graph about the season
what wait a minute no that is not the
graph that's a picture for my vacation
to Muncie you went on a vacation and you
chose Muncie Indiana yeah my wife and I
have a timeshare in Muncie Tom Muncie is
a lovely City
anyway hunting and fishing season is
winding down okay we all know that it's
already closed season and twelve so now
I've said 12 instead of trout it happens
to everyone
my marbles are full of mouths today you
know what has anybody seen my glasses I
don't even think I can
[Music]
this year I get to program my own
four-hour block I know exciting so I've
signed you all up for multiple shifts
yes just to answer phones and provide
moral support from one to one tonight
from 2:00 a.m. this example what no
Leslie please it tonight's kind of a big
night you know all my kids are away
gross
no it's Jerry's sex night that ruins sex
and tonight Greg Kinnear wasn't in ER it
was I don't think that he was Who am I
thinking
okay next mm-hmm
wow really good Jerry for my urinal I
was inspired by the death of my grandma
you said why don't you put that urine on
the men's room so people get marinate
all over it Jerry go to the doctor you
might have a mere nary tract infection
this one does showing her
it's pointillism and each dot is a photo
of a citizen of the town Jerry Jerry
are you okay Anna cherry okay what's
wrong with your arm and tell me what's
wrong with cherries are Jerry talk to me
and get your e to talk to me okay he's
okay he's got a couple scrapes and a
dislocated shoulder Oh what happened you
guys are just gonna laugh why do you
throw out your shoulder trying to swing
a honey pot off your hand I was mugged
oh my god oh I'm so sorry Jerry I was on
my way to the hummingbird feeders and I
was walking Lord Sheldon yeah is that
code for some kind of weird sex act
where children is my dog my wife named
him yeah anyway these kids that came out
of nowhere they pinned my arm back they
grabbed my wallet they knocked me to the
ground how did you counter-attack fist
to the throat did you hit him in the
bean bag there's no shame in attacking a
criminal's bean bag no I just curled up
and laid still till they left well
that's another way to play it did any of
them have weird tattoos or scars or
anything if even one of them had a
unique scar we got him I think they had
a good look damn it Jerry sorry you're
the victim Sorry Sorry
I've been staring at this board for days
so close to putting it together there's
got to be something we missed
let's go over this again the video shows
that the pie came from a high angle
so what hit your face like this mm-hmm
don't close your eyes
no no it actually was from up higher is
that about right
yeah good clean yourself up let's do
this again I mean yes my daughter might
think she is old enough to be sexually
active with her boyfriend but I'm sorry
16 that that just seems too young to be
on birth control you know I was 24 when
Gayle took my virginity
what say we just stand here in silence
and think of ideas for projects you know
what I should do I should lead a teen
abstinence workshop that might be
incredibly effective David Myers the
Jewish guy who works at City Hall once
told me something a schlemiel is the guy
who spills soup at a fancy party a
schlemazel is the guy he spills it on
Jerry is both the schlemiel and the
schlemazel of our office Jerry oh my
gosh look who's here
Leslie the nightmare is over Jerry we're
going back to work I called shotgun
everybody heard me what did jay-z little
Wayne and Drake all have in common
oh I know this one they are all rapid oh
my god the rappers Jerry okay so now
you're sure that everything is okay you
know down there they're perfectly
healthy that man has the largest penis I
have ever seen I actually don't even
know if he has mumps forgot to look I
was distracted by the largest penis I
have ever seen if Tom were a bag of
flour that flour would never grow up to
be a happy well-adjusted loaf of bread
much less a bran muffin which is the
highest honor that flour can achieve
okay so you're really gonna say no to a
none I care about Ann very deeply but I
just don't know if I'm cut out to be a
dad
you know Chris every parent makes
mistakes
lord knows I have made plenty but it's
the small victories that keep it going
when you see your little one take her
first step or will graduate college mom
I guess it just makes it all worth it
and another thing is if if like if I in
you know and then your kids and cuz
you're like I don't know and everyone's
like oh I'm sorry guys I no one ever
lets me talk this long I just got lost
it was a beautiful point and very well
said right up until that moment that you
started babbling incoherently ready and
Jerry God gross Oh Jerry guys oh good
well I think you might be having a heart
attack what are you serious wow so much
stuff is happening right now call them
a1 okay just breathe okay you're gonna
be fine Noor she's that a dinosaur
dysphoric Jerry get a grip sorry guys
apology not accepted
stop talking [ __ ] I wish I could stop
smelling dude seriously Jerry did you
eat for us for lunch Tom he's having a
heart attack why do you know that Jerry
okay a peppermint latte seriously my
goodness I love a pepper geez go ahead
we should just directly apply the food
to your claws
they can laugh at me all they want
because two more years until I retire
with full benefits and pension and my
wife and I we have bought a little
cottage on a lake and I'm going to get
myself a stack of mystery novels a box
of cigars and I'm gonna sit back and
enjoy my life hey Jerri April was just
double-checking the lunch order do you
want the salmon or the 12
you